[Music]
my name is Antony Vitolo I'm the
executive chef at Emilio's bolado on 55
East Houston the veal parmesan that I
make is a staple dish in New York in
Italy it's not really a staple dish it's
more of an American Italian dish you
don't really go to an Italian restaurant
and order veal parmesan but people in
America in New York they like you know
cheese and they love sauce so you know
you have to give the people what they
want
so you have to have veal parmigiana and
chicken parmigiana and an Italian
establishment in New York City it's a
must
veal parm is so special because it's a
different cut of meat it's more tender
and it's more of a gamy flavor it's kind
of like a red and white meat it's like
right in the middle so Bao's my go-to
[Music]
make a veal parmesan you need basically
the right amount of meat of a veal chop
you know the perfect cut of your child
is crazy big or is it 16 ounces so we
pound it out nice and thin nice and flat
so it's the size of the plate then after
you do that you salt and pepper the veal
you know you need to season it and then
you egg wash it I use you know eggs
flour and a little bit of cream it
thickens the batter up it gives like
another inch and then my special panko
bread crumbs I seize them with all
different types of seasoning you know
parsley garlic powder onion powder salt
pepper and the key is pecorino romano
cheese after you bread it I've tried
different ways of making the veal
parmigiana
I've tried deep-frying it but it comes
to crispy the pan fry with the butter
and the extra virgin olive oil gives it
the right amount of crisp that it's not
dry so after you pan fry it you hit it
with tomato sauce while the pan still
hot the red sauce we make it's been
passed down from my father to me
the sauce is special because of the
tomatoes we use our tomatoes we get
imported from Italy then you hit it with
white wine to tenderize the meat a
little bit more the alcohol breaks down
the meat a little bit and then you put
more sauce on top
in my opinion buffalo mozzarella is the
best type of cheese to use when you're
making a parmesan it just melts the best
it's nice and you know moist and it's
just a beautiful cheese and then
obviously you use Parmesan cheese to top
it off on top put it on top of the
salamander and you crisp the edges so
the edges are nice and brown and almost
a black color on around the edges and
the cheese is nice and melted and then
you got that sauce underneath and you
cut through it cuts like butter
we're known for old-school Italian
cuisine and in New York bolaños is the
bread source joint it's not offensive to
me but it's kind of like cheapening like
red sauce joint it's like we make a good
red sauce you know but we want to make
other good things and I learned you know
at a young age for my father that the
freshest ingredients bring out the best
product so no taking shortcuts
everything's fresh our pastas fresh our
meatballs are from scratch our bowling
years is from scratch and that's what
separates us from all the other
restaurants it's all about love and it's
about the passion of the food and I have
the passion and my father has a passion
and with us as a team it's very hard to
compete with the blood family
[Music]